en el primer día de las audiencias en el
comité de que investiga lo que ocurrió
el 6 de enero del 2021 se presentaron
testimonios hasta de la propia ivanka
trump ni del fiscal general william ward
entre otros funcionarios de la
administración de donald trump que
desconocen el argumento del fraude
electoral y que testifican sobre como
trompe estuvo en el centro de un
esfuerzo para desconocer los resultados
y quedarse en el poder liz cheney
congresista por wyoming una de 12
congresistas republicanas que hacen
parte de este comité reveló pruebas que
según ella no se han visto antes sobre
el plan de siete etapas de trump para
quedarse en la casa blanca a pesar de
haber perdido las elecciones en las
urnas carolyn networks policía herida
por los simpatizantes de donald trump y
nik que es este documentalista que grabó
al grupo pro voice durante la toma al
capitolio testificaron sobre lo que
ocurrió ese día hay que resaltar que
durante este día se presentó también una
hoja de ruta sobre las próximas
audiencias y también se aclaró que la
investigación sigue abierta y que el
departamento de justicia sigue
recogiendo pruebas de hecho más allá de
las investigaciones y las evidencias que
pueda ofrecer el congreso o cualquier
acusación formal contra el expresidente
donald trump y su equipo tendrá que
hacerse por parte del departamento de
justicia a cargo del fiscal general eric
harland y mencionar también que la
próxima audiencia será el lunes 13 de
junio acá en el congreso